The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hello, and welcome.
Last week we started to think
about programming.
Programming was the first
module in this class.
And it was important for
two different reasons.
First, we're going to use
programming throughout the
term in the study of all the
different things that we do.
So it's important that you learn
to program now, just so
you can use that tool.
More importantly perhaps, we
didn't just learn how to
program, we focused on how to
program in a fashion that
would let us construct
complicated systems out of a
simpler systems.
This is the way that we
can manage complexity.
This is the only possible
way that we can
make complicated systems.
So that was the more important
intellectual theme from the
first part, where we introduced
our mantra, PCAP --
primitives, means of
combination, abstraction and
identifying patterns.
That's the key to this
modular approach to
hierarchical kind of design.
Today what I want to do is start
the second major theme.
First theme was the design of
complex systems, we saw that
by reference to programming.
Today we're going to start
thinking about modeling and
controlling physical systems.
The idea here is not so much
how you construct systems--
but we will get back to that.
The idea is to characterize
the systems that you've
constructed and say something
about their metrics as being
positive or negative.
So what we want to do is, in
fact, focus on behavior.
So to illustrate that, I'll
start with an example.
This is an example that you did
in design lab last week,
or for some of you, yesterday.
The idea was to program the
robot so that it could sense
the distance to a wall.
Represented two ways here,
sort of the view that you
would get from Soar, and a more
schematic representation
showing the position of a robot,
the position of a wall.
The idea is that you can sense
the position to the wall using
the sonars.
You know where you would
like to be, because
some user told you.
You'd like to be say, half a
meter away from the wall.
And your job was to write a
program that moves the robot
from where it is to where
you'd like it to be.
So here's the kind of behavior
we might have liked--
so I'll do that again.
So we might have liked that if
you started here, you have a
nice smooth progression up to
where you'd like to be.
Very graceful, ballet type, and
you just sort of smoothly
glide into the position
that you'd like.
Some of you probably achieved
that behavior, and some of you
probably did other things.
So that might be the
intended behavior.
One way to achieve the intended
behavior is to use
what we call a proportional
controller.
In a proportional controller,
you make the command be, in
some way, proportionate to
the intended response.
So imagine this code, which
might establish a class for
finding the wall.
So the important thing-- as we
saw, for all state machines,
the important thing is to define
a start state and a
getNextValues routine.
What this getNextValues routine
does is it establishes
the desired distance to
be a half a meter.
It figures out the current
distance to the wall by
reading the sonars, and then
it specifies an action.
So the first question is what
would you like fvel to be in
order to make a proportional
controller?
Which of those expressions
makes sense?
Take 30 seconds, talk to your
neighbor, figure out some
answer between (1) and (5).
I will ask you in 30 seconds to
raise your hand with that
number of fingers.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So what's the right
kind of expression if we
wanted the controller
to be proportionate?
Everybody raise your
hand, show me
some number of fingers.
OK, the vast majority
is saying (2).
Everybody likes the idea of
current minus desired.
Why is that the right answer?
That is the right answer.
How do you prove that
to somebody?
AUDIENCE: Well, in current
divided desired, once you meet
your desired distance, you're
still going to have to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] velocity
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], which really
doesn't make sense
at this point.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So that method, we might
call extreme cases.
Think of the simplifying cases
that give you some insight
into the problem.
So one simple case is
what if desired and
current were the same?
You'd better stop.
OK, that's a simple case.
So the simple case says that you
better have one of these--
whatever the right answer is,
it better have the property
that when current equals
desired, fvel is 0.
Otherwise it's not
going to work.
And in fact, using just that
one simple case, you can
eliminate all the
ones except (2).
There are some other simple
cases, what are some other
simple cases?
Simple cases.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: currentDistance
greater than desiredDistance?
PROFESSOR: Current bigger
than desired.
So if current were bigger, that
would mean that you were
starting out way over
here someplace.
So if you were way over there
someplace, you'd want the
velocity to be positive.
The forward velocity
should be positive.
That's how you would
disambiguate the sign.
Similarly, if the current were
shorter than desired, if you
were too close to the wall,
you'd like the forward
velocity to be negative.
OK.
So that's the proportional
controller that we'd like.
So we might fill in our wall
finder class this way.
And then when we built it, if
things went really well, we
would get exactly the
behavior we wanted.
But if things went more
naturally, it wouldn't quite
work that way, and
you might get a
different kind of behavior.
Let's do that again.
So here is the resulting
behavior for that simple
controller that I just showed.
So in some sense, that's
not as good behavior.
And the way we want to think
about behaviors--
the way we're going to develop
today, is to think about
behaviors in terms of signals.
Plots.
So the first question is, what
plot best represents the
behavior that I saw here?
So which of those plots best
represents that behavior?
Take 30 seconds, talk to your
neighbor, figure out what's
the right answer?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so which behavior
best represents the
illustrated cartoon that
I showed previously?
Raise your hand, show some
number fingers so that I can
see if you're with it.
Not all correct, but more
than 90% correct.
The more than 90% answer
is number (2).
What's good about number (2)
that's not good about numbers
(1), (3), and (4)?
AUDIENCE: The initial
value is different
than the final value.
PROFESSOR: Initial
is different.
So here, I try initial and final
being roughly the same.
So what's showed here,
is a plot.
Current distance on
the y-axis, step
number on the x-axis.
And so we can see from here--
and the implication of the
axes, by the way, is 0.
So the implication of the
vertical axis is it intersects
this at 0, unless I label
it otherwise.
And similarly, this horizontal
line intersects the vertical
at 0 unless I label
it otherwise.
So that's the point (0, 0).
So the implication here is that
the initial and the final
values are the same,
as they are here.
Here they're not, what makes
(2) better than (1).
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the current distance is
decreasing [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The current distance
starts out bigger
than it ultimately is.
So we start out bigger than
the final value, the final
value is presumably
half a meter.
We start out roughly
twice that far, and
then we see some approach.
The approach is not monotonic.
So the answer is (2).
Why do you think
it under-shot?
So on the way to going from
one to one-half, it
transiently went through
something
smaller than one-half.
Why do you think it did that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because [INAUDIBLE]
this way, there's a small--
there's a small interval of
time when its moving at the
velocity where it couldn't
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So it's a small
interval of time between when
it does one thing, and it
does something else.
When it senses and moves,
for example.
So there could be a time delay,
in the system and in
fact, that's true, there
is a time delay.
So it takes some amount of
time for the sonars to
register the distance.
Then it takes some amount of
time for the computer inside
the robot to register that
the sonar has told
it something different.
Than it takes some time from the
time the computer commands
the wheels until the robot
starts moving.
All of those cumulative effects
mean that you have the
potential to overshoot where
you're going, because there's
delay in the system, there's
inertia in the robot.
All of those reasons can
lead to overshoot.
And the point of today is to
figure out some way of
predicting and correcting
for those kinds
of unintended behaviors.
So what we will do then, is
develop an approach focused on
signals, not systems.
So, so far, we've been thinking
about how do you
build the system?
Now we're going to think
about behavior.
We're going to think about
analyzing that behavior.
And the focus is going to be
on what was the input, what
was desired?
What was the output,
what was achieved?
So we're going to be looking
at those output signals in
order to figure out how
good the behavior was.
That approach is called the
signals and systems approach.
The idea is characterize your
system-- whatever that system
is, a physical system, a
mathematical system, a
computational system, whatever
it is, think about it by the
way it transforms an input
signal into an output signal.
That's kind of a bizarre way
to think about systems.
So let me just illustrate that
by way of a system that you've
all seen before.
OK, here's a simple
system, right?
You've all seen this, right?
Anything like 8.01
ring any bells?
OK, so that's a simple system,
you all know how to solve it.
There's a gazillion ways
you could solve
this system, right?
Free body diagrams, kinetic
energy, potential energy,
there's a gazillion ways
you could do it.
You all know how to do it,
that's not the point.
The point is, that we're going
to learn a different
way to solve it.
We're going to think about the
mass and spring system--
not like potential energy and
kinetic energy, not like free
body diagrams, we're going to
think about it as transforming
an input signal into
an output signal.
So the input signal--
it's kind of arbitrary what I
use besides the output, but
clearly the thing I have control
over is my hand.
So it seems natural to associate
a variable with the
position of my hand,
that would be x.
Also it seems natural to
associate a variable with the
position of the mass, that
could be the output y.
That's not unique.
Every time we try to solve a
problem we ask ourselves,
what's the meaningful input,
what's the meaningful output?
The meaningful output
could have been the
force on the spring.
I'm just sort of arbitrarily
saying for the purpose of my
analysis, I'm going to consider
the input to be the
position of the hand,
the output to be the
position of the mass.
And I'm going to think about the
mass and spring system as
a box that transforms
x into y.
So rather than thinking about
it in terms of free body
diagrams, and kinetic energy,
and potential energy, I'm
going to think there's some
input signal x, and there's
some output signal y.
And what I'd like to do is
given x, calculate y.
OK, bizarre, why would
I do that?
One of the reasons I want to
do that is that it's a very
general way of thinking
about behaviors.
It works for the mass and spring
system, it works for
water tanks.
What happens if I have
water flowing into
a tank that's leaky?
Well, it leaks into another tank
which is leaky, and that
leaks more.
Completely different physics.
Probably wasn't covered
in 8.01.
Probably is something you
could figure out.
The point is that from the
signals and systems point of
view, I'm going to map this
physics, whatever it is, into
this structure.
Think about the tank system as
the system that transforms
some input.
The input is that there's water
spurting for some small
interval of time.
The output is that there's
water coming out.
And the idea is that I'm going
to characterize the system--
whatever it is, as the rule
that transforms the input
signal into the output signal.
Here's a third example.
I could think of a cell
phone system.
Here again, there are very
complicated ways we could
think about the system, but
I'm going to take the
particularly simple approach
called signals and systems.
Then I'm going to characterize
the phone system by the way it
transforms some input sound
into some output sound.
And as you can imagine, there's
a way of thinking
about performance in terms
of that transformation.
Ideally, we would like this to
bear some resemblance to that.
So the point then,
is that we're
going to focus on behaviors.
And to do so, we're going to
think about the signals and
systems approach.
Represent a system, whatever
it is, by the way it
transforms inputs
into outputs.
One of the reasons we
like the approach is
that it's so general.
So you can use it for virtually
any kind of a system
for which you can develop a
mathematical underpinning.
You can use it to analyze
electrical systems, mechanical
systems, optical systems,
acoustic systems, biological
systems, financial systems if
you're on the dark side.
So there's lots of different
kinds of systems that are
amenable to this kind
of approach.
Also, this approach has
a nice modularity.
Having represented a cellphone
by transformation from sound
in to electromagnetic field out,
as illustrated by this
cartoon depicting sound going
in and having a radio wave
transmitting to a tower.
Then we represent tower to tower
communication some way,
maybe via an optical fiber,
maybe via a satellite.
Then tower to cell by the same
kind of reverse transformation
that we used in the first one.
We can piece those all together,
we can treat them as
modules, because each box takes
an input signal and
makes an output signal.
The method is oblivious to
the underlying physics.
That affords us a certain
amount of power.
And in particular, it's
very modular.
You can put together modules
that represent very different
physical substrates.
That allows us to
go back to PCAP.
If the underlying
representations for the
different physical substrates
are the same, we will be able
to-- and we will over the next
three weeks, develop a bunch
of techniques for combining
multiple modules into one.
That provides the same kind of
abstraction and modularity
that we saw in programming
for the last two weeks.
So that's the idea.
What we want to do is represent
a system by the way
it transforms an input signal
to an output signal.
There are many different kinds
of inputs and outputs, but a
fundamental distinction that we
are going to have to make
is continuous time,
and discrete time.
This system works in what
we will refer to
as continuous time.
Because my position of my hand
is a continuous function of
the continuous variable, time.
The robots, by contrast, work
with what we will call,
discrete time.
Steps.
It turns out the math for those
two different approaches
are very different.
And we will focus entirely in
this class on discrete time,
because our area of application
is the robot.
It's not that continuous is
deeper, or harder, or anything
like that, it's different.
So we'll focus on
discrete time.
And the point of today then,
is to develop some
representations for signals and
systems of this free time
nature, that will let us analyze
and predict behaviors
of systems like the
robot system.
The first class of methods for
representing such systems is
difference equations.
Difference equations are a lot
like differential equations,
except there's no differentials,
there's
differences.
Difference equations are the
discrete time analog of
differential equations for
continuous time systems.
Simplest possible
example here.
Say I have an output y, that for
reasons that I don't care
about, I know can be represented
as the difference
between two values
of the input --
x at time n, and x at
time n minus 1.
That's a way to represent the
behavior of a system, a
discrete time system, by using
a difference equation.
That's in fact, almost
a complete
description of the system.
So let me just explain the
way you would use that.
It's almost-- because
I didn't tell you
anything about the input.
I'll tell you something about
the input for the purpose of
example, where I'll
use the simplest
possible input I can imagine.
Something that we'll call
a delta function.
A delta function is a signal.
It's a discrete time signal.
It has the value 1 if the time
index is 0, and has the value
0 everywhere else.
It's, in some sense, the
simplest possible signal that
we could imagine.
So it's natural to
start there.
So what I want to do now is
think about if this were a
characterization of the system,
and if this were the
input to that system?
What would the output be?
That's after all--
that was the question that
I posed at the beginning.
We would like to build a
representation for a system so
that we can predict the output,
given the input.
So how does that work?
So given the difference
equation, all we need to do is
step through it.
OK, it's trivial.
We call that analyzing
by step by step.
So given the difference
equation, given the input
signal, all we need to do is
sequentially go through the
different values of n, and think
about the implication of
the system on that input.
So if I were to use the value
of n, being minus 1, this
general form of the difference
equation tells me that the
minus 1 value of n for the
output is related by this
difference, with the input.
So y of minus 1 is x of minus
1 minus x of minus 2.
Since both of those are 0, it
says that the output at time
minus 1 is 0.
Trivial, right?
Trivial.
And similarly, we can just
iterate through the solution
to the whole signal.
So y of 0 is x of 0 minus
x of minus 1.
x of 0 is that special
one, that is 1.
So now we get 1 minus
0, which is 1.
y of 1 is x of 1 minus x of 0.
Now the special one is on the
other side of the minus sign,
so the answer is minus 1.
y of 2 is x of 2
minus x of 1 --
they're both 0.
And in fact, all the answers
from now on are going to be 0.
So what I just did is a
trivial example of --
I use a difference equation to
represent a system, and I
figured out the output signal
from the input signal.
That's the method
that we call--
that's the representation for
discrete time systems that we
refer to as difference
equations.
Difference equations
are very powerful.
As we will see, of all the
representations we look at,
difference equations is the most
compact representation.
But there are features of other
kinds of representations
that are also valuable.
So the next representation
I want to look
at is a block diagram.
What I'm trying to show here is
a picture, a diagram, that
represents the same system that
we just analyzed with
difference equations.
Here though, I'm thinking
about it as
a signal flow path.
I'm thinking about what's the
cascade of operations that you
need to do on each sample in
order to get from the input to
the output?
So the difference equation said
every value of the output
should be equal to the
corresponding value of the
input less the value
before that.
I represent that in a block
diagram by saying there's a
straight through path, y of
n is equal to x of n.
The plus just adds the signals
on these two paths.
So y of n is equal to x of n.
Subtract out, because I'm
multiplying by minus 1.
Delay, so I'm getting
the one from before.
So this block diagram just is
a symbolic representation of
that difference equation.
The value of the
block diagram--
we'll see several of them,
but one of them is focus
on signal flow path.
If you want to visualize the
transformation from input to
output, the block diagram can
provide visual insight into
what that transformation
is like.
So as before, if I gave you
this representation rather
than the difference equation,
you could still step by step
and figure out the
way it worked.
It's still easy.
There's one new caveat here.
We have to start the
system in a state.
The state that we will usually
talk about is what we will
call, at rest.
At rest just means all the
outputs of all the delays are
initially 0.
So that specifies the state of
the system at the time the
signal was turned on.
So the system is at rest,
which means that all the
delays start out with
output equal to 0.
So at rest means this delay
has an output of 0.
Well, if I tell you the output
is 0 times 0 for this delay,
then it's a simple matter of
stepping through what is the
output for each corresponding
input?
So if I--
the special value of the delta
function is that it's
1 at the time 0.
So at the time 0, there's
1 coming in.
That 1 makes it through
the adder, adds to 0.
Well, this is 0 because
it was at rest.
So the 1 adds to 0 and
the output becomes 1.
Notice that the 1 also goes
down this path, and goes
through the gain of minus
1 to give me minus 1.
But I'm in step 0.
So at step 0, the output of the
delay is 0, not minus 1.
So the output then, for time
equals 0, is y equals 1.
Just like we solved for the
difference equation--
after all, I'm hypothesizing
that those two systems are the
same, they better give
me the same answer.
So then at the next instant, as
the time index goes from 0
to 1, two things happen.
The input goes from
1 to 0, and the
delay box gets updated.
The delay is now reporting
to me the value
that was at its input.
So the output of the delay,
which had been 0 because it
was at rest, becomes minus 1.
So then what happens?
The 1 goes to 0, the 0 goes to
minus 1, the 0 adds to minus
1, and we get an answer
which is minus 1.
Then the input becomes 0.
That 0 comes down here,
the minus 1 goes to 0.
We end up with 0 being added to
0, and the next answer is
0, et cetera.
So the idea then, is that you
can step through the block
diagram representation, just
like you would a difference
equation, it's just that now
we're thinking about these
blocks characterizing the
system, rather than thinking
of math as characterizing
the system.
Why on earth would
you do that?
What's good and bad?
What's the relative merits of
difference equations verses
block diagrams?
Take 30 seconds, talk to your
neighbor, figure out some good
feature of each.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, we'll start
with the easy one.
What's a feature, what's a
property of the difference
equation that makes
it very good.
I already said it, so.
What's good about the
difference equation?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They can be solved
mathematically.
PROFESSOR: They can be solved
The block diagram could
be solved, maybe not
mathematically, but kind of.
Could you refine that
a little more?
What's special about difference
equations that's
different from block diagrams?
Oh come on, I said it.
AUDIENCE: Use math?
PROFESSOR: They use
math, yes yes.
They're concise, a
little, right?
It's a very simple expression
to say that.
It's by contrast, a bit more
complicated to draw this
picture, right?
It's mathematically
concise, right?
It's completely accurate,
self-contained, concise, small.
It's a very concise
representation of a system.
So why would we want to
use block diagrams?
Can anybody think of any good
reason for block diagrams
other than Freeman's up front
saying, do block diagrams?
AUDIENCE: Electrical
engineering?
PROFESSOR: Electrical
engineering.
There should be a deeper
reason, I would hope.
I don't disagree with
that reason.
Why do electrical engineers
like this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It's a more physical
representation of this.
PROFESSOR: It's more physical?
Is there anything that
you can see that you
can't see in math?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In the way that you're
actually going to be
programming it.
Like, you're gonna make the
delay machine, you're gonna
make the state machine that
multiplies them by negative 1
and you're gonna see how
to connect them.
PROFESSOR: That's a
really good point.
It's kind of isomorphic
to the implementation.
Everybody get that?
It's kind of a picture
of the way you
would build the system.
Along those lines, there's
some bit of information--
there's actually more
information in this one, than
there is in that one.
There is exactly one bit more
information in the block
diagram, what's that bit?
AUDIENCE: Delay?
PROFESSOR: Delay?
There's kind of delay
by the n minus 1.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The input and
output are explicit.
Yes.
The arrows are the
big difference.
You can't tell from the
difference equation, what's
the input and the output?
You can tell from the block
diagram, what is the input and
the output by the direction
of the arrows.
So there's more information
in the block diagram.
There's another way of thinking
about it, and this is
kind of a summary of several
comments that
came from the audience.
The difference equation
is declarative.
It tells you a true statement
about what the system will do.
The block diagram
is imperative.
It tells you what to do now.
Take the input, put
into an adder.
Take the input, multiply
by minus 1.
Put it into a delay.
Take the delay output,
put it into an adder.
The representation with a block
diagram is imperative.
It tells you what to do.
So there's extra information,
but it comes at a cost.
It's a more complicated
representation.
It's a whole picture instead
of just an equation.
What we'd like to do, and what
I'm going to do now, is
develop a different mathematical
approach where
you get a difference equation
that has the same properties
of concision, the same
conciseness, but also contains
all of the information that
was in the block diagram.
And the way to do that is
to change our focus.
And this is the big abstraction
of the day.
Change our focus from thinking
about samples, to thinking
about signals.
Stop thinking about x of n,
start thinking about the
input signal x.
This is the same kind of
lumping that was key to
abstraction in Python.
Put all the interesting data
together into a list, put all
the interesting operations
together into a definition.
Here put all of the interesting
samples together
into one signal.
So what we want to do, is
develop a math by which we can
operate on signals instead
of samples.
So what I'm going to do is
replace the representation x
of n, little x of n, with cap-X.
Cap-X means, all of the
n's, it's the signal X. Cap-Y
means the signal Y. And I'm
going to reinterpret
all the boxes.
This box means, take this
signal, the whole thing, all n
values on it, multiply it sample
by sample, by minus 1.
Flip the whole signal
upside down.
So I'm going to reinterpret all
of the operations on the
block diagram in terms of
signals, rather than samples.
To do that, I need a
representation--
a mathematical representation,
for the delay box.
And I'm going to call that R,
the right shift operator.
If you apply the right shift
operator to a single X, it
takes the whole signal X and
shifts it to the right one.
That's all it does.
So I'm going to say Y equals
R applied to X, or more
abbreviated, RX.
Simply says, let Y represent the
signal that is the same as
X, except every sample was
shifted to the right.
The entire signal was shifted
to the right.
That's going to let me
represent this block
diagram this way.
Y--
the whole signal Y, is the sum
of the whole signal X,
subtract out R applied to X.
Or, even more concisely,
calculate Y by applying to
X the operator 1 minus R.
So I'm thinking now
of an operator.
An operator is not something
that works on a number.
Operations work on numbers,
operators operate on signals.
So I'm thinking about
operator expression.
I'm going to try to formulate
the transformation from the
input to the output in
terms of operators.
The way I take X, which is the
input, and turn it into Y, is
to operate on it with the
operator 1 minus R.
OK, just to see that you're with
me, connecting signals
and samples, assume the
Y is RX, which of the
following is also true?
Take 30 seconds, talk
to your neighbor.
Figure out some number
-- (1) through (5).
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so which
representation works best?
(1), (2), (3), (4), or
none of the above?
Everybody raise a hand,
tell me some number.
OK, virtually 100% correct.
The answer was (2), why
is the answer (2)?
Can somebody explain
that concisely?
No no,no.
I asked that wrong, of
course everybody
can explain it concisely.
Do I have a volunteer to
explain it concisely?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The R operator just
shifts all of the values in X
of n to the right.
So you just add 1 to each
of these basically?
PROFESSOR: So you think about
it-- so a good way to think
about this is to think
about simple cases.
Right?
That's the same thing I
talked about earlier.
What's a simple case?
Well what if X--
let's imagine that
X is simple.
So let's say that X
looks like that.
So X is delta.
What would happen, what
is the signal RX?
It's a right shift operator.
So what does the signal
RX look like?
Shifted to the right, right?
That's the whole point.
So the right shift operator
gives you that signal, and
we've said that that's Y. So is
it true that Y of n is X of
n, for all n?
No.
Is it true that Y of (n
plus 1) is equal to X
of n for all n?
Well, is it true
for n equals 0?
So if we did n equals 0 we get Y
of 1, which happens to be 1.
And X of 0, which also
happens to be 1.
And if we choose any other
n, we would get two 0's.
So at least for this simple
case, and it seems to be true,
and if you think about building
upon this simple
case, you can convince yourself
that number (2) is
always true.
And in fact, the general rule
is going to be that the left
hand side has to have a number
that's bigger than
the right hand side.
Which is only true
for number (2).
So the idea then, is that by
changing our focus, by looking
not at samples, but looking
instead at signals, we can
generate an algebra that looks
for all the world like
difference equations.
Except it knows the direction
from the input to the output.
So it's more powerful.
And in fact, this new algebra
is going to obey some very
simple properties which we
can get a hint at here.
If we were to cascade two
systems, imagine this system
which looks just like the system
we've been looking at,
but it's cascaded
with a clone.
The question is, what would be
the behavior of that cascade?
Well, according to our operator
representation, this
Y1 signal is just the 1 minus
R operator applied to X.
Analogously, the Y2 signal
should be a similar 1 minus R
operator applied to the Y1
signal, which gives us a very
concise representation
for the cascade.
The point of the slide is that
the operator representation
gives us a representation that
is just as compact as
difference equations.
It has other features, that it
can be manipulated just like
difference equations.
So if we continue with this same
example and try to think
of the transformation on a
sample level, we could say
that Y2 is Y1, the straight
path, minus Y1 delayed.
But then we could substitute for
Y1 of n, that Y1 of n is X
of n, this path, subtract
X of (n minus 1).
Similarly, collapse, and we
get a simple expression.
Now if we think about that same
sequence of operations in
operator notation, we get a
much simpler expression.
Throw away the index arithmetic,
it's just R. So
the Y2 operator is 1 minus R
applied to the Y1 signal.
The Y1 signal is 1 minus R
applied to the X signal.
The total is 1 minus R the
operator squared, which by
polynomial math is just 1 minus
2R plus R squared, the
same thing we got there.
The point is, the operator
notation is just as compact as
the difference equation
representation.
And it contains all
the information
that's in block diagrams.
And it's just as easy to
manipulate as a polynomial.
So it's got lots of features
that make it superior to
difference equations.
The most important of which,
is you will be able to
understand all systems that we
represent using the R operator
using polynomial arithmetic,
something you
learned in high school.
There's nothing new here.
That's what we like.
Representations that simplify
the task of finding an answer.
We'll be able to find the
answer to these operator
expressions by treating
them as polynomials.
So you can get a feeling for the
way that works by looking
here, the power of this.
So the power here is that, among
other things, you'll be
able to use the operator
representation to prove
equivalences.
The idea is that here's a
system that we looked at
before, that was the cascade of
two simple delay systems.
Here's a somewhat more
complicated, somewhat simpler,
representation.
The point is, it's different.
And if we compare the operator
representations for the two,
we see that they are the same.
And what I'm about to prove,
is that when the operator
representations are the same,
the systems represent the same
transformations--
provided they all
start at rest.
The provided is important.
Obviously since they have
different delays in them, if
the delays didn't all start out
at 0, the differences in
the delays could propagate
into the output.
So all of the statements that
I'm making are premised on the
idea of initial rest.
The other important thing to
remember about operators is
that it's a higher level
of abstraction.
We can think about the operator
as composing things,
but the things that are composed
are whole signals,
not samples.
And here's an illustration of
how to think about that
previous example.
How do you think about this
transformation, 1 minus 2R
plus R squared.
What happens when you apply
that operator to an
input signal X?
Well let's say that X was
our unit sample signal.
In order to apply this operator
1 minus 2R plus R
squared, all we need to do is
think about each component.
1 times X is X. Minus 2R applied
to X is minus 2RX.
Plus R squared X is just plus
R squared X. So we start out
with X, which is a unit sample,
minus 2RX means shift
it to the right and multiply
by minus 2.
Shift it to the right,
multiply by minus 2.
Plus R squared X means shift
it twice to the right.
So the result, this operator
1 minus 2R plus R squared
applied to X is just the
sum of these things.
So you can think about the
operator expression, it's just
like algebra, except that
the elements are
signals, not samples.
And as I alluded previously,
you can make powerful
statements about the way these
operators work which map
isomorphically onto
polynomial math.
So for example, it's easy to
prove that if you were to
cascade the 1 minus R operator
with R. So start with X, apply
1 minus R. Start with X, apply
1 minus R. Then apply R.
That's going to result in the
same signal, assuming initial
rest, as if you were to
flip those operators.
The way I can see that is by
thinking about signal flow.
You'll remember that I said,
one of the features, one of
the powers of the block diagram
representation is that
we can look at signal
flow paths.
We can use that as a way
of proving things.
This system has two signal flow
paths, the one that goes
straight through that way, and
the one that goes down this
way and up that way.
Because of the addition, all it
does-- the adder just adds
the result of those
two flow paths.
So the first flow path
introduces one delay, the
second flow path inverts
and puts in two delays.
So there are two ways to get
from the input to the output.
Similarly here, there are two
ways to get from the input to
the output.
One of them goes through a delay
and then goes through
the adder, the other
goes through two
delays at a minus 1.
But that's the same two
signal paths that
were in the top one.
So that's a way of using the
block diagram to prove a
relationship about
the operator.
What I've just showed, is
that the operators obey
commutativity.
So what I was able to show is
that I can commute these two
operators--
doing a general proof is
slightly more complicated, I
proved it in a special case.
But the general case
works too.
Just like polynomials,
operators commute.
And I indicated why you should
think that's true by thinking
about signal flow paths.
Multiplication distributes
over addition.
I apologize, the diagram
in your notes is wrong.
This is right.
I will always post the notes--
I get up in the morning, I
make coffee, I read the
lecture notes, and I say,
oh my goodness,
there's a wrong figure.
In this particular case, one of
the staff members wrote me
an email and said, Hey
Freeman, your slides,
something or other, is wrong.
He was right.
So this is the right diagram.
So the idea is that if
multiplication distributes
over addition, we should expect
that R applied to 1
minus R, would give
R minus R squared.
And we can again get a feeling
for why that ought to be true
by thinking about the
signal flow paths.
The two signals flow paths that
represent-- so the signal
flow path that represents here,
this says take the 1
minus R operator and apply it
to X, then apply R to the 1
minus R operator, result.
As opposed to this one says,
apply the R operator to X,
then apply the R squared
operator to the X
and subtract them.
If you think about the signal
flow paths through those two
systems, they're also the same
two signal flow paths.
And here's a more complicated
example that shows
associativity.
You can think through
that, same idea.
The reason that the idea--
the big important point is,
difference equations are a
good representation for
discrete time systems.
They're mathematically
compact.
Block diagrams are a good
representation, but they have
more information.
They tell you what is the input,
what is the output, and
what are all the different flow
paths through the system?
Operators kind of combine the
best features of both.
It's mathematically concise,
it tells you which is the
input and which is the output.
And you can visualize all the
flow paths by thinking about
all the ads in the operator
expression.
OK, to make sure that
everybody's up with me, how
many of the following systems
are equivalent?
You have 30 seconds.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so how many
of those are equivalent?
More hands, more hands.
Not necessarily more fingers,
but more hands.
OK, about 75% correct,
roughly speaking.
OK, how many distinct signal
flow paths are going through
the first system?
How many distinct signal
flow paths can you see?
Well, here's one.
How many more are there?
AUDIENCE: Three.
PROFESSOR: Three more.
So here's one, here's one,
here's one, and here's one.
All you need to do to think
about this system, is think
about all of the signal flow
paths through all of them,
make a sum, and see how many
of them have the same sum.
So the path with the greatest
delay through this path is two
times two delay delay.
Two delays with a
multiply by 4.
What's the path with
the biggest delay
through this one?
Also straight through.
Also delay of two, also
a coefficient of 4.
How about this one?
So that's this way.
So they all have the same paths
with maximum delay.
The delay is 2 and the
coefficient is 4.
This one has four possible
paths, this
one only has three.
So there's one straight
through this way.
There's one that has
one fewer delay.
And there's one that
only has--
so there's a straight through
one, there's a delay of 2, and
there's a delay of 1.
So let's do the straight
through one.
This one has a straight
through path.
No delay, coefficient is 1.
This one has a straight
through path,
coefficient is 1.
This one has a straight
through path,
coefficient is 1.
So all three systems have the
same maximum delay path, they
all have the same minimum delay
path, we only have one
in the middle yet.
This one has two ways
to get a delay of 1.
2 delay, 2R, or 2R.
Since they're both 2R, they
sum, so that's 4R.
This one only has one way that
we can get 1 delay, and that
is to come this way and then
go that way, that's 4R.
This one, to get 1 delay,
I take the center
path, and that's 4R.
Each path has the same ways to
get through the system with
zero delay, 1 delay,
and 2 delays.
They're equivalent in the sense
that if you started them
with initial rest, they would
all generate the same output
given the same input.
So the answer's (3).
OK?
So far I've only worked with
systems that propagate the
inputs systematically through
to the outputs.
We call such systems
feedforward.
Things are a little
bit different
when you have cycles.
We call such systems feedback.
So what I want to think about
now is how do you think about
a system that has a feedback
loop in it?
The interesting thing that
happens when you have a
feedback loop is that the
operator expression no longer
represents a simple sum
of input signals.
Let's look at what
happens here.
So Y is apparently the
sum of two things.
It's the signal RY, which
comes around that way.
Does everybody see that?
So if I think about labeling
this input as X, labeling this
output as Y, then the correct
label for this point is--
don't everybody shout at once.
If this can be labeled as the
point Y, what is the correct
label to a label at this point?
RY.
So the signal Y must be, RY
plus X. What that says, is
that if I apply the 1 minus R
operator to Y, I should get X.
OK, that's a fine operator
expression, except that it's
not a formulaic operator
applied to the input.
The operator is applied
to the output.
OK, the difference here is
the difference between an
imperative system, like we
talked about block diagrams
when we were thinking
about samples.
The block diagram tells you
what to do step by step.
Regardless of whether you have
feedback, the block diagram
always tells you take X of n,
add it to Y of n, whatever.
There's an imperative
rule, do this.
We took the block diagrams and
we turned them into operators,
and we ended up with something
that is not imperative.
This is much more the kind of
statement we got when we did
difference equations.
This is a statement of truth,
it's declarative.
If you tell me the signal X,
it must be true that the
resulting signal Y when operated
upon by 1 minus R, is
X. So the idea is that it's
a declaration, it's not an
imperative rule.
Does everybody get that?
So this statement up here told
me a rule, start with X, apply
the 1 minus R operator and
you will get Y. That's an
imperative operation, do this.
This is a declaration.
If you tell me X, Y must be the
signal that when operated
on by 1 minus R, gives you X.
But it doesn't tell me a way
to find it.
It tells me a truth, but it
doesn't tell me how to find
that truth.
So let's go back,
let's back up.
OK, we got a representation,
we like the representation.
It's concise, it has many
of the features of block
diagrams, it doesn't seem
to be imperative.
Well, that's a problem.
So let's back up, think about
how this same system that ran
into a problem with the
operator, think about what
must the answer be.
Well the answer we can figure
out by doing step by step.
Imagine that it starts
at rest, so the
output starts at 0.
And now I just tick through
the samples.
So when the first sample comes
in, X is equal to 1, I'm
thinking about the unit
sample response.
We call the delta function
the unit sample.
When the unit sample at time n
equals 0 comes in, it has a
value of 1.
The 1 adds to the initial
condition, which is
0, to give me 1.
Then, this output is 1, so
when the clock ticks, the
input goes from 1 to 0, but the
output of the delay goes
from 0 to 1.
So when the clock ticks,
I get another 1.
And that persists.
Does everybody see
what's going on?
So I initially had a 0 coming
out of the delay.
The unit sample made the first
output be one, but then that 1
fed back in to make this be 1.
Which combined with the next 0
to give me the same 1, and
that state persisted.
What's different, is that the
output signal persists long
after the input went away.
In fact, there is a prescriptive
way to figure out
the relationship between the
input and the output.
It's just that it takes an
infinite number of delays.
Here's an alternative system
that would generate the same
response to a unit sample signal
as was generated by the
simple feedback system.
It needs to generate the
answer 1, 1, 1, 1, 1 --
when the input is just 1.
Well, the output at 0 happens
through this path.
The output at 1 happens
The output at 2 happens
through this path.
3--
et cetera.
There's a separate path for
every one of those separate
components of the output.
That's how we can think about
this construction.
The input had a single non-zero
entry, the output has
an infinite number.
We can think about that as
resulting from an infinite
number of paths, or something
similar, about the simple
feedback system, which can be
represented by that operator
representation, and the infinite
feedforward system.
This is a simple feedback
system.
This is an infinite feedforward
There's something the same
about those two.
In fact, they're equivalent in
the sense that if all the
delays start out with initial
conditions of 0, they will
generate the same response to
all possible input signals.
Those two signals are
equivalent, and
that's proved here.
All you do is you say, OK, Y2
depends on X2 this way.
If X2 is the same as X1,
I can substitute it.
But X1, according to this rule,
looks like 1 minus RY1.
When you multiply out this
mess, you get Y1.
What I just showed is that if X1
is equal to X2, then Y1 is
equal to Y2.
Those two systems
are the same.
Well that's weird.
So there's something
the same about that
operator and that operator.
We write that this way.
So here's the feedback system,
we think about that as
representing the operator Y over
X, 1 over (1 minus R).
So in order to calculate X,
cross multiply by X. Y is the
operator, 1 minus
R applied to X.
So we want to say Y is the
operator 1 minus R applied to
X. What is the operator
1 over (1 minus R)?
Well, if you didn't know
anything but polynomial math,
you might have expanded
this in a series.
And in fact, that gives you
exactly the right answer if
you were to expand 1
over R in a series.
So, for example, evaluate it
using synthetic division,
evaluate it with a Taylor
series, however
you want to do it.
Think about R as though it were
a number, just like you
would if it were a polynomial.
Expanded just like you would
if it were a polynomial.
And what you see, is that
there's a representation for
this operator 1 over (1 minus
R) that is equivalent.
That's exactly the same as if I
applied the operator 1 plus
R plus R squared plus R cubed to
X. Those two are equivalent
in the sense that if both
systems start out at rest, and
if they are both applied to
the same input, they both
generate the same output.
So that gives us that way of
thinking about operators that
have numerators and
denominators.
So, to make sure you're up to
speed, a system is described
by the following operator
expression.
Determine the output of the
system when the input is a
unit sample.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's the first
thing I should do?
OK, this is one of those
systems that has the R
polynomial in the bottom.
So it says that X must be
the same signal by cross
multiplying--
X must be the same signal as
the (1 plus 2R) operator on
the Y. OK, that's backwards.
That's not the way I want
to think about it.
How do I make that into a
forward statement that tells
me what operator gets
applied to X?
The answer is that.
So what do I do?
Multiply by--
actually you could
cross multiply.
How do I convert this into an
operator that looks like just
the numerator times X. Yeah.
AUDIENCE: 1 minus 2R
plus 4R squared.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
What I want to do is convert
it by synthetic division,
Taylor series, whatever
method.
I want to think about
what would 1 over (1
plus 2R) look like?
What's the reciprocal
of 1 plus 2R?
That is 1 minus 2R plus
4R squared, et cetera.
So now I have this, which
I apply to X,
which is a unit sample.
So now I want to think about
applying this operator to the
unit sample signal.
But that's easy.
The first term just
brings out delta.
Minus 2R applied to delta
shifts the delta by 1.
Gives me delta of n minus 1,
and multiplies by minus 2.
And that whole mess then
just says that my
output looks like this.
If the input was X, which was
a unit sample signal, my
output has an infinite
number of terms.
Each one is a delayed version
of the predecessor, and the
weights go 1, minus 2, plus 4,
minus 8, plus 16, and diverge.
So what we just did was
pretty complicated.
We just solved a block diagram,
but we did it with
polynomial math.
We did it with math that you
learned in high school.
That's the point.
In fact, the point of today is
that any system that's built
out of simple parts--
delays, adders, scalers,
that sort of thing--
can be represented by a
difference equation.
Fine, that's good, difference
equations are wonderful.
They can equivalently
be represented
by an operator equation.
The operator equation has
more information in it.
It knows how to get from the
input to the output.
It's imperative.
It's easy to manipulate.
You use the same rules that
you use for polynomials.
So all in all, this is a
more powerful kind of
representation.
And any system that can be
represented by a difference
equation can similarly
be represented
by an operator equation.
That's why we're focusing
on operators.
So final question.
Think about--
do everything backwards now.
Here's a block diagram,
find the
associated difference equation.
And the idea is to take
advantage of operators.
In the interest of time,
let me just do it.
If we wanted to--
because I'm running
out of time.
So I could start with the block
diagram, I could stay in
block diagram domain.
Presumably that will
work, that's hard.
I want to do the easy way.
So convert it to operators.
How do you convert a block
diagram to operators?
Replace the delays by R,
label all the signals.
x becomes X, y becomes Y. I
don't have a name for this, so
I'll call it E, error.
I don't have a name for this, so
I'll call it W, who knows.
And then I'll express each of
the relationships imposed by
the plus sign, this
R or this R, by a
line of operator reasoning.
The plus says that the E signal
is X plus W. The R says
that the Y signal is R applied
to E. This box says that the W
signal is R applied to Y.
I get three equations in R. I
just solve algebraically.
None of this difference stuff,
none of the square brackets
with n's in them.
I just use algebra.
So I solve it algebraically
and I get this.
And that translates into a
corresponding difference
equation, showed here.
The point.
The point is three different
representations.
Difference equations, block
diagrams, operators.
Operators are easiest.
Even when I was asked to solve
a problem that has no
operators in it, it's easier
to cast it into an operator
expression, solve it in the
operator domain, and then turn
it back into a difference
equation.
Starting next week, we will
figure out much more powerful
things that we can do
with operators.
This is just the beginning.
So with that, let me just
summarize that we looked at
three representations, and the
point of the labs for the week
are going to be to exercise
this, to get some experience
with representing signals
in Python.